is a question I got followed for both of
you guys okay which of those
institutions organizations families
supported and loved the Kennedy family
and the Trump family
oh
I see we I see what we did there yeah
good job so you know what the moral of
the story here is yes why don't they why
don't you like those two families what
do those two families do that you don't
like why did you have such a problem
with Joseph Kennedy Why do you have such
a problem with this guy here you were
cool with them you know one of the
things that Trump just released is a new
book that just came out of uh he
released I don't know if you've seen
this book or not it's all letters that
was written to him so Oprah Winfrey
writes a letter saying Hey listen I want
to tell you as busy as you are thank you
so much for making us feel so special
hey Alec Baldwin hey thank you so much
you know for a guy as busy as you and as
tough as you are in New York when it
comes down to you're such a nice guy and
thank you for letting me use your
Penthouse Sweden New York all these
letters he released from all the
celebrities it's like what happened all
you guys love me until the day I rent so
the point the part that concerns me is
the following
in indirectly whether we know this or
not independent independent content
creators that are pushing against the
envelope you know you're part of the
anti-establishment crowd whether you
know this or not we're
anti-establishment just because we're
not going the traditional route okay The
Establishment is who the journalists
that went to Columbia University and
they're reading the script and the
teleprompter tells them what to say and
they say it or somebody tells them in
their earpiece what to say to say is
somebody telling you in your ear what to
say we don't have that that's not our
model we don't have teleprompters you
know there's not a teleprompter here for
fresh to read what he's doing you're
letting you rip so for me and the people
out there that are watching this the
question you have to ask yourself is the
following do you want
to have because we all fall under one or
three categories we're either part of
the oblivious crowd the oblivious crowd
is a crowd that doesn't know anything
yeah I'll never forget this I told the
story the other day I have an uncle
named Albert Albert cesarean he was my
he's my dad's best friend I hope he
feels better he would come to our house
when we lived in Granada Hills I'm 21
years old 22 years old and he loved
watching Bernie Mac from Kings of Canada
I don't know if you've seen that the
skin
right he would sit there and he would
say can you put put on that man I love
listening to that man he would sit there
laugh for 30 minutes tears coming down
his eyes cracking up and I would say
Albert do you understand what Bernie Mac
he didn't speak English just I have no
idea what he said I said so why are you
laughing he says he's so funny I said
well what did he just say I have no clue
we're in the kitchen my dad told me the
most incredible thing we're in the
kitchen and my dad says hey Patrick I
want to warn you on something he says
what's that you know all these books you
keep reading he says yeah
yeah let me tell you what happens if you
keep reading these books I said what's
that he says the more you read
the less you're going to be as happy as
that innocent man right there is that
man right there knows nothing
he just wants to have good food good
conversation have people around them he
is so innocent so happy that we all need
a little bit more of that right but
unfortunately it's also the innocent and
the happy that don't do the reading that
the other control The Establishment yes
so you're either part of oblivious crowd
oblivious crowd where you're like I
don't need to know this kind of stuff I
don't care what they do I don't care
it's part of your risk that you take or
you're part of the establishment crowd
you're like man I want people to make
decisions for me you tell me how to live
my life you tell me what school to go to
you tell me my kids need to learn at
school you just determine the curriculum
you you tell me everything that's good
for me or then there's the
anti-establishment the
anti-establishment is the crowd that
says what they say you know what can I
ask why we're teaching that yeah why are
we increasing taxes in this area any
reason why we are making the corporate
taxes something that's going to be the
same worldwide why are we all agreeing
to make it 15 why can't we compete for
other countries why are we doing this
the anti-establishment people are the
most annoying people in the world you
know why because all they do is ask
questions and there's nothing more
annoying to The Establishment than those
who ask questions you know something
might say that that what that is also
called is getting red pilled yeah of
course right so yeah whether it's
politically whether it's in
relationships it's it's like the
understanding of like everything that
you thought that you knew
maybe it ain't that true everything that
the government told you everything that
we learned during the last couple years
hey you can trust this trust the science
trust vouch you trust whatever
who got canceled people asking questions
yeah I don't know about this where's
that mask what hold on you're telling me
the the Wuhan lab what we can't talk
about this lab leak well okay you can't
talk about the mass thing you can't talk
about what women are supposed to be uh
you know everything nice sugar and spice
and everything nice at home we can't
hold these women accountable hold on
women deserve less why why is that
this is getting red pills so in many
many facets what we talk about is
getting becoming a free thinker so I was
uh when you were talking about John F
Kennedy and Trump and the similarities I
mean let's talk about John F Kennedy
real quick you know he's real big on
going against organized crime he's made
his brother the Attorney General uh he
was against the military-industrial
complex he was um critical of uh of a
certain state that I won't name that
potentially well actually not
potentially it's actually factual at
this point they stole the nuclear bomb
from the United States you know uh they
took a bunch of uranium out of
Pennsylvania and they shipped it through
South America destined for
um a certain place if you know what I'm
talking wink wink wink wink which we
can't say Here on YouTube
um and Kennedy was very involved in
having them checked for having nuclear
weapons and next thing you know he gets
killed right and then you got Trump
who's not a politician he's a
businessman first so he's obviously more
interested in getting things efficient
versus necessarily making everybody feel
good
um he has his own money so he doesn't
need people to Lobby friends to the same
degree as other politicians uh APAC
and at the end of the day he knows that
uh you know the White House and the
government in general is filled with the
swamp that's why I called the swamp and
I'm going to drain it so you know is he
completely innocent of other like uh 100
innocent no but he's better than a lot
of these other politicians and I would
say those are some of the similarities
between the two
um they kind of went against the grain
and you know that's why Kennedy got
killed so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
all right foreign